bring in president Trump's personal
attorney Rudy Giuliani
Rudy first are you in touch with the
president have you spoken to him the
last couple hours or tonight what I
think of course he's my client and
therefore I can't tell you what I talked
to him about particularly at a time like
this
it's attorney-client privilege I know
the Democrats don't respect that or any
other constitutional privileges the
president has I think you're absolutely
right I think the Democrats have stepped
into something way beyond what they
realize it reminds me of a fighter who
was swinging wildly against a really
skilled fighter who has a great right
hand and puts him right down they have
walked into something that I was hoping
they'd walk into for six months and what
they've exposed is probably what's going
to turn out to be one of the major
scandals of the early part of the 21st
century which is Joe Biden it's a lot of
money Laura it's not just Ukraine it's a
pattern of conduct it's a very serious
pattern of conduct it really goes back
to small-time stuff when he first got
into the Senate with his brother who was
enriching himself on Biden's public
office and then the numbers got
outrageous during the Obama
administration
five six million to a son who's a
seriously incompetent person who got put
on a board of the most corrupt company
in Ukraine Rudy I have the records I
have the records of a three million
dollars warranted payment to mr. Biden's
son I have the records I have the dates
if it went from Ukraine Latvia Latvia to
cyprus cyprus to you that's a that ask
your two lawyers this that's called
evidence of guilty knowledge illegal
transfer I want to move the conversation
for because we've hit this and we've had
you want for months talking about this
so we've nobody nobody paid attention to
it until now whatever going to corrupt
media paid attention well everybody has
their you know but I think enough
Democrats did which is what I think
they're doing I think they're covering
up for what will turn out to be massive
corruption in the Obama administration
he got 1.5 billion from China what about
point five billion from China
phone the phone transcript I guess
that's gonna be released an official
telling Fox from the White House tonight
that there are a quote few words in the
transcript that will raise eyebrows but
it's nowhere near as inflammatories the
Democrats suggest is no Ranieri word
it's nowhere near what Biden did or
Chris Murphy by the way who should be
impeached he went to see the president
of the Ukraine and he told the president
of the Ukraine that if he cooperates
with the president they'll cut off aid
that's a quid pro quo that's a good Pro
that's threatening hey should be
outraged that Chris Murphy Murphy she's
a very interesting view of Cardona what
the prime I don't know what the crime I
don't even actually pronounced it
correctly I don't know what the crime is
but the reality is that Joe Biden
actually may have very well committed
something called crimes 1.5 billion
dollars from China to your son when
you're negotiating with China and you're
failing in your entire paid Joe Biden's
office China didn't invest in a drug
challenge son with 1.5 billion they
bought the vice president of the United
States and even if you're a Democrat you
should be shocked by that this political
party is so corrupt it stinks and when
the Biden corruption comes out and we
look at how much money Clinton made or
if the Secretary of State's office and
look at how much money Kerry stepson
made in that same transaction I wasn't
making any in the Obama in a second
because the Washington Post tonight has
a story out you're the focus of it
that's not a big shock this what it says
in part you know though the
whistleblower report focuses on the
Trump szalinski call officials familiar
with its content said that it includes
references to other developments tied to
the president including efforts by
Giuliani to insert himself into u.s.
Ukrainian relations Rudy he did all of
this one US official said this
show that we're in it's him injecting
himself into the process insider saying
you muck this up your response man I
really did and you know who I did it at
the request of the State Department I
never talked to her Ukrainian official
until the State Department called me and
asked me to do it and then I reported
every conversation back to them in Laura
I'm a pretty good lawyer just a country
lawyer but it's all here
right here the first call from the State
Department the debriefing of the state
so why are they why are they out to get
you this story is filled because my guy
I will compliment myself because I do a
pretty good job for him and they try to
destroy everybody around him but they're
not going to intimidate me in fact I'm
gonna work harder because I don't get
intimidated by bullies I don't get
intimidated the corruption I always
thought Joe Biden was intellectually
challenged but a nice guy I never knew
the depth of this corruption its massive
it's shocking and if I played a role in
getting that out I did a service to my
country and I'm proud of it and
everything I did is defensible and
everything I did is legal and most of
what they are doing is to cover up for a
crime and I'm happy to have them
challenge me because every time they've
challenged me they go down and we win
because they are acting improperly yeah
they are acting with an abuse of power
and the president of the United States
conversation with that president if you
consider what a crook Joe Biden and his
son were was demanded it was necessary
you cannot let the vice president United
States allow his son to enrich himself
to the tune of millions why are you the
one to do this why isn't this the role
of the Justice Department or the FBI
white ask you the personal attorney the
president did it I think that's that's a
question that just layman was saying
okay I get it I that should be
investigated but why is Rudy role you
know running the show on that why isn't
it FBI and just in main justice that's a
very good question
because the FBI's performance since his
entire investigation including up to
this moment is flawed why am i doing it
Laura can't you figure it out
I'm his defense lawyer I'm defending him
he's my client
I don't know only Donald Trump is not
entitled to a defense in America finding
him by investigating Biden because
because one of the things that the
prosecutor that Biden had fired and then
the prosecutor that Biden helped to put
in one of the things they did was to
dismiss a case against an organization
that was collecting false information
about Donald Trump about Paul Manafort
and feeding it to the Democratic
National Committee okay that explains a
was that was run by George Soros
who then hired the crooked FBI agent who
is now working for George Soros Morra
this stinks
this is Tammany Hall New York politics
to the tune of a billion dollars it is
it stinks I spent my life as a
prosecutor investigating crooked
Democrats crooked Republicans I don't
care who's crooked they should go to
jail these people abuse power and you
know why because that crooked press
corps enables them because they don't
cover them the way they covet
Republicans there are two systems of
justice in this country they go after
Republicans if we say something wrong
they allow Democrats to steal millions
and they don't care the Clintons enrich
themselves on public office to the tune
of hundreds of millions the Biden's got
1.5 billion from China which had to be a
deliberate act on the part of China to
buy the vice presidency it cost a lot of
money to buy it
they guarantee vesting they didn't
invest in the hedge fund
because because it made money it made no
money had now on Chinese are not stupid
yeah they don't have any money for no
reason
there's only one reason the Chinese
spent that money to buy Joe Biden's
office that office doesn't belong to him
it belongs to the people of the United
States and if a
and it can't vindicate that then it's a
sad day for America I am proud of my
president because he is trying to clean
up a swamp that is much more than
American people realize well I think no
disgusting rush Schumer warned about the
you know deep state they'll always find
a way to get you and there seems like
there are no not if you have courage
yeah there are people in so a little
fluke a little bootie hold on hold on
there's people inside this
administration I've said this from
January 5th 20 of 2016 they are leaking
there were people at the very beginning
leaking it went rolled all the way
through the deep state and a lot of
their people are now putting other
networks as commentators it's absolutely
reprehensible I've never say anything
like it but Rudy there's a thing in this
story is why you've cleared up a lot I
think a lot of people don't follow every
every iteration because it's complicated
two people don't know but it's it's
important that people understand this
because when they hear stuff then they
can you know say oh I heard that spin
and it's wrong so what is the deal about
this Ukrainian ambassador to the US
because part of this story again broke
tonight is that you were putting big
pressure on her as part of this scenario
yeah that US ambassador of the Ukraine I
was sitting in my office in November of
2018 and a very prominent investigator
that both the gentlemen you just have on
know came to me and told me there's a
story about the Ukraine and what the
Democrats did there that'll shock you
and I didn't believe it at first
Viton wasn't involved it was all about
collusion which by the way is massive
right I mean and people were paying for
it like George Soros and the American
ambassador was deeply involved in it and
the FBI agent who was investigating it
was deeply involved in it she is now
working for George Soros the FBI agent
is working for George Soros making
hundreds of thousands of dollars she was
involved in it back then in January of
2016 the Obama White House told
Ukrainian officials go dig up dirt on
Trump and Manta for Nancy Pelosi doesn't
care about
that who in the Obama administration I
say the Obama Obama White House that was
that was what was told to you know
that's been reported in the hill by John
Solomon now I've seen I've seen I've
seen some of the documents and then Joe
Biden removes this prosecutor he says he
didn't know his son was under
investigation that's absurd
that he never told he never talked to
his son about his son farm business do
you believe that don't you think I can
prove that he did you think I'm stupid
you think I've given you all my evidence
they have walked into a trap so this is
a gift to you then this whole thing is a
big gift to the American people for
transparency your dog waiter to give me
the sunlight maybe just maybe we will
finally investigate a Democrat like we
investigate a Republican maybe just
maybe we won't do the big Hillary
Clinton fix like the FBI did to let her
out of crimes that was so horrendous and
so obvious did anybody be prosecuted if
Biden gets away with the 1.5 billion
then we don't have justice in America we
just don't we've lost the FBI and and
who knows what else we can't we got bill
burr over at justice no way you
listening yeah their inability to
investigate this is astounding you know
how it first came to me it first came to
me from this very prominent investigator
telling me for one year they were trying
to get this information to the FBI so
you asked me why did I do it because the
FBI didn't do their job maybe they're
afraid that they'll expose who could
agent I will show you the statements
from five Ukrainians that say we
desperately tried to get the information
to the FBI and we were blocked by the
Ambassador who eventually got fired or
just here you know what we're just
hearing that Trump is going to be
meeting with the Ukrainian president
2:15 tomorrow
would you please emphasize defected
Ukrainian president has said I wasn't
pressure this again is where the
Democrats have taken up Ukraine says it
wasn't pressured that transcripts are
coming out
the counts by the way yeah really
present accounts and extortion alleged
store shootings the vikram or and it
said I wasn't pressured it doesn't
matter if shift was he all right already
sorry to cut you off you got to get your
voice back we have a lot more to catch
you everybody covered when we come back